es una normativa bastante importante
sobre todo precisamente después de estos
tiroteos y es importante también porque
es una de las pocas que se aprueba de
forma bipartidista es decir los
republicanos y los demócratas se
pusieron de acuerdo uno de los aspectos
relevantes de esta ley es el punto en el
que se prohíbe a los abusadores
domésticos que fueron enjuiciados
adquirir un arma antes esta ley sólo
aplicaba para las personas que estaban
casadas y que estaban pues enjuiciadas
de violaciones en sus hogares de abuso
doméstico pero ahora pues esta ley se va
a expandir y va a aplicar también para
las parejas sentimentales que han sido
acusadas o están siendo investigadas de
uso doméstico para que no puedan
adquirir un arma sin embargo pues los
demócratas dicen que todavía hay vacíos
en esta ley porque no es retroactiva y
pues no aplica para las personas que
cometieron una violación doméstica
simple en estándares estadounidenses y
esto los demócratas pues lo ven
igualmente con
cristóbal y que reacciones se han
producido hasta este momento
porque es uno de los es el líder
demócrata del senado es una política es
una figura importante a nivel portugal
eeuu dice qué pues ya todo el país
quería ver acciones reales en cuanto a
las armas así que aunque no era el
paquete que estaban esperando los
demócratas se necesitaba darle al pueblo
estadounidense alguna respuesta frente a
esto también hablo nancy pelosi que dijo
que aunque no haya sido el paquete que
querían los demócratas pues es igual un
paso positivo y después mitt romney el
republicano el senador también dijo que
pues toda esta discusión además de ser
política es muy importante porque al fin
y al cabo va a evitar más tiroteos en
eeuu
cristóbal pues a usted muchas gracias
por esta ampliación estamos muy
pendientes de lo que ocurra con esta ley
en eeuu